[Music]
whether you're buying a ticket for the
subway
stopping by mcdonald's for lunch
or shopping for a computer
the prices of these things don't change
much in japan but in the u.s they're
going up and inflation hit a three
decade high in october whereas in japan
inflation is about zero and has been
that way for nearly 30 years in fact
there have been periods when prices were
actually falling deflation
so we went shopping around tokyo to see
how low prices that may seem great for
our wallets could actually be one sign
of a less dynamic and slow growing
economy
if you want to buy electronics in tokyo
this is the place to be and coming to
akihabara is also a good place to
compare prices with the us and see how
japan is dealing with inflationary
pressures differently
in the u.s the price of computers jumped
eight percent in the month of october
compared to a year earlier whereas in
japan prices of these notebook computers
actually fell a little more than one
percent
and one of the reasons for that big
difference is demand
as the us has begun to recover at least
economically from the pandemic there's
been an upsurge of demand the u.s has
seen a lot of supply chain pressures
including shortages of parts and
materials like semiconductors that go
into so many products including
electronics
and also container ships have been
blocked at ports such as los angeles and
long beach so they're backed up and that
means a shortage and in some cases it
means retailers feel that they can or
must raise prices
japan faces many of the same supply
chain problems as the us does but in
general it has not resulted in price
increases in japan one reason is that
consumer demand in general is not so
strong in japan and hasn't been and
that's part of the inflation story that
japan has never really experienced what
we see in the us right now
but companies in the u.s found it hard
to meet that higher consumer demand
because they aren't able to find enough
workers so that's driving them to boost
salaries to recruit workers and the cost
then is passed on as higher prices and
you can see that happening on a menu at
mcdonald's
here in tokyo a big mac was the
equivalent of about three dollars and
forty cents in the us they're actually
raising prices at mcdonald's and
according to the company that's largely
because of wage increases
mcdonald's said wages have gone up at
least 10 percent so far this year at u.s
restaurants and a survey finds that
companies in the u.s are setting aside
an average 3.9 percent of total payroll
for wage increases next year the most
since 2008.
in japan we just haven't seen that wage
price cycle develop
one reason that wages tend to rise more
slowly in japan is because of a more
rigid labor force
people are staying at companies for a
very long time and they really don't
have the flexibility to switch
jobs without great personal loss so
companies are not really under pressure
to offer these people wage increases
because wages don't go up here people
aren't willing to open up their wallets
one survey by the bank of japan found
that about half of people think of price
first when making a purchase and they
tend to reject any retailer that raises
prices
companies have found they're better off
keeping their prices level
so for example train ticket prices in
japan haven't gone up that much for the
last 30 years
whereas in the us the minimum fare on
the new york subway has more than
doubled over the same period
besides train tickets you see flat
prices really all across the economy for
example eon which is one of japan's
biggest retailers putting signs in its
stores saying prices frozen exclamation
point at least until the end of the year
prices that don't change very much can
be reflective of a society that doesn't
change very much and that could be a
good thing or a bad thing depending on
your perspective
japan is still a pretty vibrant place
it's a stable society it has kept its
unemployment rate low but it tends to be
accompanied by other phenomena that are
not so favorable such as static wages
such as an economy that seems to lack
some of the dynamism of the u.s where
you have a new company like tesla
storming onto the scene and seizing a
big part of a market like cars
you can see some of that recently in
growth figures japan's gdp shrank at an
annual pace of 3.6 percent in the third
quarter whereas in the us the figure was
2.1 percent growth low prices and prices
that never go up may sound like a good
thing but they can also reflect larger
economic problems in a country